Atchoum !
Vous avez vu mes yeux…
Pourquoi les ferme-t-on quand on éternue ?
L’éternuement est un mécanisme qui permet d’évacuer les impuretés qui se glissent dans nos narines,
les grains de pollen par exemple, pour les empêcher d’atteindre nos poumons.
irrités par ces intrus, de petits cils
qui tapissent notre conduit nasal
envoient un message au cerveau
qui déclenche la tempête.
Les muscles de la cage thoracique se contractent.
L’air est comprimé, il remonte jusqu’au nez
et dans le canal lacrymal qui débouche au coin de l’œil.
Tout se passe comme si une poussière s’y était glissée.
Les paupières se referment par reflexe.
Au passage, l’air qui est expulsé peut atteindre 50 km/h.
Pas mal !... pour une « capsule de déconfiné »
Allez à demain ! Et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.
Atchoum !
« A tes souhaits ! »
Merci la petite caméra !
Si vous avez aimé cette "capsule de déconfiné"
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne pas les rater,
abonnez-vous et activez la cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...